um i know you guys are you're incredible
at that you're you guys are incredible
it's just going right for the
sweating
off the bat yeah off the bat remember
podcasts were chill remember when you
were
an emotional mma
yeah i mean you know
but it's fun it is yeah it's a lot of
fun and i like being uh confrontational
a little bit but it's such a lot of love
you know i think it's healing i mean to
get like to be able to be of service to
other people and get paid to be
relentlessly honest
pretty [ __ ] cool yeah it's like you
hacked the system in a way um on the
road were you doing any clubs or just
theaters uh i was doing clubs in the
beginning of the pandemic because you
know it was things where i have capacity
weren't open so i did but after that i
did the theater tour yeah and you like
that i i prefer clubs like i love doing
clubs because i like to do two shows a
night and theaters to sh i don't like
adding two theater because of the
meet greets after just too late you know
like i don't like you know i like clubs
because you get to do one set and be
like that didn't go well i want to do
this again like right now you know like
i think that's where you get better but
i think clubs there's a certain game you
have to play where you're like i have to
prove that i can sell out clubs and i
know that's part of the thing yeah i'm
sorry i've proved that i can sell out
theaters oh south theater even though i
would rather do yeah cobbs and comedy
works yeah i i for some reason i just
i'm getting pushed to do theaters
but i just don't it's less money i mean
it is less money
theater says yeah oh i didn't know that
so you don't have the food the drinks
the production it's a bit yeah all right
so i mean depending on i'm not willing
to charge more than 60 70 for tickets i
just ethically i just won't do it yeah
at clubs i can do less ticket prices i i
40 is the mo i think the most i charge
and then but i like um
i like just the interaction of people
right yeah and also it gives room for
people to bring people that don't know
you mm-hmm like oh yeah i'm just gonna
go here and it's like it's clubs are
more of a casual affair for people you
know i love cl i'm saying this as i'm
saying this i love clubs until 20
minutes into your set they dropped the
check
and i'm like why the [ __ ] yeah am i
listening to people be like did you who
got the sam like i'm like why am i at
the store okay at the comedy store right
and i i i forget to [ __ ] even tell
the [ __ ] waitresses right but every
time i'm about to tell a punch line you
have some person stand in front of the
[ __ ] r right and i say the punch line
and you have to admit this
it gets 80 percent less of a volume in
terms of laughter
like 80 it's like
there's everything there is a pew
research can you pull up the pew no i
have a
mayo no no
i've been doing it enough to know it
happened last night right this once it
goes and i'm about to say the punch line
i go uh oh this is my favorite when
people make up fake statistics and then
they deliberate they're like it's like
the the audience laughter goes down like
80 like 70 80 percent
what fake math
do in your ass yeah all right exactly
that's 50 percent that's true and that's
i think that's part of becoming a better
comic like you see people that just go
straight from like youtube fame or and
they go straight to a theater and
they're just shoveling [ __ ] down their
gullet and you're like oh yeah that's
because they've never had to compete
with five checks dropping at the same
time and people looking at their bill
like
as an audience member my whole life it
really does [ __ ] up the moment for me
because i cannot drown out stimulus
around me so if someone is deliberately
they're arguing about a check next to me
it really [ __ ] up my experience all i
can think about yeah it's all here i was
uh i was just in austin and rogan and i
went to go see christina positsky at one
of the venues there it's called creek in
the cave and she was just like working
on new stuff and we was the first time
i've sat and watched comedy in a like a
comedy venue and not gone up and you
know i can't i probably couldn't even
tell you what 15 years yeah and i'm not
sitting in the back as a comic and we're
just sitting just watching her you know
she's the best yeah she's a friend i
just want to go see her
and um i was like the i was like the
substitute i was like
like people are
opening their where there's originals
they're talking to each other they're
texting
they're taking videos they've got fidget
spinners like don't know i'm like hey
i'm going out in the lobby i hear music
people's phones are going off i was
excuse me like i was a monster because i
i was like
she probably didn't notice any of it but
i was so just protective of just being
like i cannot believe all the [ __ ]
rigmarole that goes on while comedians
are on stage i would rather just be
delusional and not know
yeah i find joe to be very sweet lately
joe's very yeah yeah that was a joke
gave me a bruise
[Laughter]
so you know what i mean what
oh my zipper thanks george
single
easy tiger should we call us
no when you found out that we had broken
up how would you feel
um
relief no um
uh i i mean look i it's
i was thinking about it because i i was
like catching up on everything um
yesterday and
it's
i'm sad i mean
i'm sad because i know how sad
y'all are and i think for me i have that
and how it's heartbreaking i mean life's
it's like getting an animal that you
know is gonna die at some point right
you know what i mean it's just that like
they're not gonna die there's no they're
not gonna know there's no way around it